Dingaan thank you watch on back there
Johnny doing podcast you see you guys
names last week where you go this
excerpt is brought to you by naturebox
start smacking healthy with nature rocks
these rocks make snacks that actually
taste great and are better to use free
from artificial colors flavors or
sweeteners so you can feel good about
snacking right now you go to
naturebox.com/tyler Julianne you will
get 50% off your first order
let's naturebox.com/tyler Julianne's
also we have lifts this week ladies if
you want extra money driving for lists
you should do it right now because guess
what if you use our URL which is lift
calm which is l YF t calm Tatiana Julian
you will get a 500 new $500 new driver
bonus that goes to you and your wallet
and your pizza addiction okay everyone
is a pizza addiction me thank you left
taking a shoebox Thank You falses mono
later all right so so know what if we
just said so like over know like last
podcast when we said what if we just had
a podcast mainly consisted of me saying
I don't and you think I do
we did have that conversation was like I
do I don't do so what are you so ah this
week we wanted to make a game and before
we start the game I want to explain
where we're coming from over the weekend
there was huge crazy giant news made
about Donald Trump basically executing a
Muslim band which consisted of a number
of Muslim countries anyone who had
basically a green card living in the US
as it says
and we're from those countries they were
background is from those countries or
their background or they affiliate with
being Muslim there's a whole array
millions and millions and millions of
millions I think over a hundred million
people fell under the span
so basically Trump was trying to make it
so they were just able couldn't get back
into the country so if you were on
vacation and you were coming back you're
a citizen of the US you couldn't get
back in and made crazy news there were
protests at all these airports and it
turns out that the ACLU declared this
ban unconstitutional and basically said
no this won't happen and you know I
wanted to bring it out just to
acknowledge this happen to some crazy
news this whole week and it's kind of
crazy watching this happen to protest
and it's scary stuff does the whole you
know the whole BAM is a scary thought
especially when it's executed and almost
carried out in to fruition so we wanted
to take this acknowledge that it's
terrible and acknowledge that you know
discrimination is never ever ever okay
like that what we wanted to take the
word ban and kind of make a game out of
hey yeah so we wanted to basically turn
it into a fun thing a fun a lighter look
on the whole thing we by no means are
trying to take this lightly but rather
acknowledge how serious it is
acknowledge the gravity of it and then
and then in a way distract you maybe um
continue banning citizens from getting
back to their homes and families
horrible it's pretty ridiculous it's
horrible and the United States it's not
it's not the same as like the visa or
bedding systems that we have in place
you're asking people that are citizens
like you can't come back with furnaces
okay if this had been in Australia then
Rome and we gently wrong were acting
well we're going out of town on Friday
so if we were actually gone right now
and in a world where this was an
Australian aliens I don't think so
I wouldn't be able to get back home my
closer with Kerry in Rome has a daughter
and a family and so hmm
we just want I just want to reiterate
again that we we are one thousand
percent against this bad we stand with
every American of every color religion
race and everyone has the right to live
here that this country every thing about
this country was built on immigrants and
anyone who's going to forget that is
making a fool of himself so that's as
much politics as it's going to be right
now because you know this podcast ain't
about politics well yeah and also like
you can you can maybe disagree with that
statement or where Gillian just said or
or what's going on you can disagree with
that but the point of the game is to
sort of make light of the fact that our
president literally just was like hey
you know what citizens of this descent
you know welcome here and what like it's
sort of just a little out of left field
at least I don't know just seems I know
that he said that he was going to do
things like this so this is the reality
yeah but the game in and of itself is to
just pretend that we're sort of under
we're working for a president making
bans on other things other thing we are
you more ridiculous the least of the
three evils yeah so basically what we
did so hopefully even if you disagree
with what Julian said you can still
enjoy this game and have it and I'm not
really you know I don't view what I said
I said at the political position this is
more of just like a human rights
position it's like what I feel about
people or things with that said my name
is on your podcast and you're allowed to
say whatever you like that man I
disagree you can we can talk in the time
and that goes for every week I have I
sit here with a voice and I take that
voice very seriously but at the same
time you know I'm not always right and I
always value your input it's you know
it's constructive in whatever but yeah
you know I appreciate the back-and-forth
want you guys to understand that when
we're talking about serious things it
may not be a fun thing that we look
forward to doing or that we relish on
the podcast but sometimes I do feel it
is our duty to at least acknowledge
these things and to give you a little
bit of our view on what's happening in
the world like I said this is not a
political podcast we really do generally
stay away from politics but I do you
know sometimes I just feel the need to
just be honest with you guys because you
know what makes everything better
sometimes when [ __ ] gets weird Cuba
laughs no I'm serious it really does
help yeah so we were we're gonna laugh
now and and you guys can join us and
watching so what we did was we took this
cup can we smash it on the ground okay
now we took a entire 32 32 32 different
little piece of paper and we wrote
things on them that would in this game
be banned so if you've ever done
anything on these notes you need an so
what we're going to do is we're going to
take three out of time and we're going
to decide what's the thing that we would
like to live with as a band offense the
most in our country so where we work for
some fictitious presidents was trying to
ban all this stuff and we get to choose
one of these three yeah you're going to
come into me like here's my three things
I'm thinking about about doing which one
should we go for first and yes we have
to pick the police's enabled and they're
all terrible irritating like eight but
let's let's just get it are you ready
I'm ready
the left bodega - you got one you ready
for this
she goes by the way it's half the
podcast this is because jenny is holding
it I'm not rolling them little all right
the first law were presented with is if
you take a selfie in public okay yeah
okay each of the second law is if bath
salts are on your maybe list okay and
this is a law if you can't get left 100
pattern [ __ ] I am already favoring that
one even if and everyone that takes a
selfie in public no no I'm paper
this one I want to get rid of and icky I
want this one to be the rule I want
anyone who can't die without Japan to be
where wrong with you it was a pic like
the least problematic one way that's
problematic think about all the people
in the United sick aunt deadlift 100
pounds I don't hang around those people
I'm kidding um yeah I mean that's all
elderly people basically all disabled
people babies or a lot of you believe on
the grip stage yeah baby
Amy you're gone let's see the does
everything else malls or have this
that's ridiculous up oh my god okay I
think that's all Sonia maybe less anyone
can do whatever drug they want period
all the time in public in professional
settings
that's my law okay uh paying yourself in
public we can we can take selfies let's
leave that and I think that this like if
the least of the three that's the worst
with bath salts is on your maybe list
and there's no way this is how I know
this is a better law than the other two
this is like all speculation yeah so
like maybe you'd be harder to actually
get rid of people because you can't
prove that it's on there maybe list but
yeah that's true
could be fair if someone couldn't
deadlift 100 pounds of weight they could
pick up 100 British pounds off the
ground and bypass the law that's true
it's so smart but babies probably
wouldn't think about doing you know we
can't have that you know we can't have
if you can't develop so many problems I
don't know anything all children would
be gone I don't know it all joy all
right please gentlemen the new BA the
United States's if that's all sir on
your maybe list please Big Al you're not
welcome here you ban so if you do bow
falls and you like it that fun just
don't have any maybe list right yeah it
doesn't say anything about he just saw
you about so if you've done Gaza or
currently do Valley I would consider
them do it or don't do a
all right so this is are we going to
read all the band list at the end yeah
maybe check along the back to the term
forget what you got don't do that don't
come on it's really water come on
that doesn't sound peaceful be all right
if you've ever gotten a divorce
you bet you been people with any belly
button on oh and your band if your Wi-Fi
password is a pun Oh nah I personally
want it for if anyone's going to make
their Wi-Fi password opponent you're
putting a dad joke out into the universe
or whatnot such as oh yeah one you think
about
like you can't you can't ban people
because they got divorced well you could
punish them my death in the last game we
played members and presidential realize
roulette people with any belly buttons
that means I'm out of here
I haven't any bit belly button any of
these could be someone's you should've
written out a belly button no those are
the words we need to get out skidding
from say dumb yeah if your Wi-Fi Wi-Fi
that's right are the least bad software
guys ladies and gentlemen United States
if your Wi-Fi password is a pun you've
been you go yeah I'm so sorry
detained at the airport yet can't come
back your own you know Jillian more
Julian go ahead what do you got
if you don't babe you could be banned
oh okay here open this one or not into
the mic
alright so if you don't vape you would
get in you I mean there's a large
population of people that don't pay the
truth
mine is if your brother is a [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] you get this alright and then the
last one is if you ain't eat ass these
are really eloquent um I personally
think I personally think if your
brother's a [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
a lot of that fall upon you link in it a
little bit your fault so I wouldn't I
wouldn't mind betting brothers of [ __ ]
ass [ __ ]
we can't ban if you don't babe that's
like a lot of people can't do that a lot
of Apes you have to manufacture its part
down to the economy let's get rid of
that one fat all right all right so
you're left one if you ain't eat ass and
your brother's a [ __ ] happiness I think
this is available offense if you a
mean-ass and your baby date country what
like what if somebody doesn't want to
you to ask they're banned because
another they wrote they ate you guys I
think this is more realistic if your
brother is a [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
you're banned so it's not subjective fun
you can make an argument I still want to
keep this card okay there's German
United States America if your brother is
a [ __ ] ass [ __ ] you been and you can't
come back that is a Gary God you don't
know what I got it's a presidential
roulette podcast if you guys all right
if you want this card just at me I'll be
able to you if you ain't yes
do you eighty that you got one or two -
all right move it all because all the
people that are just like in a hospital
like I can't eat ass right now come
without in your face you get either oh
my god
first Wow grams was weird if you won't
derelict these balls when commanded not
you been all right if you've never
posted on Facebook about Roxy oh geez
that's a lot of people if you click bait
on the Reg the avenged yeah okay okay so
here's my reasoning we got to get rid of
if you won't dare elect these balls on
different amounts for this for this i'm
i personally think as much as it's
frustrating and annoying because an
outsider of crossfit to see people post
no talk about cross from facebook it's
just a hobby you're going to hurt anyone
anticipating kills on your rag week they
don't on a rag you click thing on the
rag you will be dead from the country I
personally think that was amazing I
agree the United States of America if
you click bait on the rag you will be
banned from this country
actually it's all [ __ ] up actually
this one should be implemented IRL
no you wouldn't get banned maybe maybe
your channel gets in trouble you man you
can't click me on the rag on the rag
dollar egg okay sorry
can you imagine oh if that was a real
law like there was click date court you
can everybody down there like I declare
the title has been clickbait you will be
going you're banished what in Siberia
clickbait court [ __ ] back a good idea
clickbait Court LLP is copyright
trademark you can't use that I just I
just trademarked it if you on ironically
wear Crocs you're done I'm done
my mighty and ban you and your Crocs can
get out I am banned [ __ ] I really wish I
just didn't say clickbait court on the
podcast that's a good idea I want to do
that quick Nate Clark
yeah these are the story if you ever let
a fart on fire ever you bang your bed
and if you have a problem with mammals
get out all right what's what's the
least bad of these three if you have a
problem animals who's going to have a
problem with mammals just IRL in general
yeah because people can wear Crocs
shouldn't have to be able to ban them is
because they like comfortable Footwear
and if you have let a fart on fire good
for you for you
ladies and gentlemen in the United
States if you use a good neighborhood
digital image don't kick you out there's
nothing to do business yep hmm don't
have problems the middle mmmm the
myth-making please because okay sir the
book email you book what do you got
right if you don't sit on Santa's lap at
the mall right now all right
I have if you use the word tchotchkes
all right if you drop what a plane land
Oh Blake a giant crop when planes Lynn
passed mine I feel like if you don't sit
sit on Santa's lap at the mall that's
your choice
that's you can't enforce that that's too
much well yes you can because it's so
tough and if your kids men your
fascinator it's ridiculous though I'm
not the president we're both the cabinet
people or whatever look inside the cabin
we're in the area hey yeah please a
collage later ah naturebox Oh
Julianne you did not you did not order
boy
oh my god
my favorite snacks are the corn maze
crisp and the turn chocolate on another
really good brand very good minds are
also pretty ridiculous delicious next
guys deliver train ticket or education
boxes I'm gonna talk much very good
thank you in order as much as you want
as often as you want with no minimum
purchase you can cancel anytime it's
really convenient you choose the snacks
you want from the catalog and you get
them delivered to your door you go to
naturebox.com/tyler snack catalogue or I
like to call it a snack a log and
there's over 100 snacks for you to
choose from and they add snacks new
sticks all the time based on customer
feedback which is awesome so if you
think hey this is a really great snack
and this is a really great snack but
what if you use them you like hey
naturebox refuse them
they're gonna be like okay you're high
but that's a great idea but for real
naturebox has a an array of great
tasting snacks with no artificial colors
flavors or sweeteners so you can feel
great about snacking and not guilty with
nature max you'll never get bored you
can try new snacks each month inspired
by it like I said real customer feedback
and if you try a snack that you don't
like naturebox will replace it for free
which is awesome right now you guys get
50% off your first order when you go to
naturebox.com/tyler Julian that's
naturebox.com/tyler Julian and if you
need to go somewhere after you stuff
your faces next trial it especially
ladies right now lift is looking for
female drivers and if you join now with
our URL you get an extra $500 driver
bonus lyft is the ride-sharing app that
lets you be your own boss pick your own
hours earn up to 1500 bucks a week just
driving your car are you someone that
loves people are you someone that works
and would like to make money on the side
or are you someone that has odd hours
and you can't get a normal 9:00 to 5:00
job well you can sign up and be a driver
for list at lyft com+ jena Julian and
again at $500 driver bonus you can make
up to $35 an hour you can drive mornings
nights weekends or if you have a few
hours spared in your day randomly you
turn on driver mode and you going to
pick some people up and make some cash
also there
other ride-sharing apps out there we
know a lot about them the list is the
best because they treat their drivers
right and only lyft drivers earn their
tips from within the app so you don't
have to wait weeks to get paid so you
get tipped you don't have to wait a
while to get paid you cash out instantly
with Express pay and you make your own
hours guys it's your own car it's a
great way to earn some money so right
now go to a nice calm that's ly ft.com
Sauceda julian and start making money
and get your $500 new driver but it
wiglet Thank You sponsors
sounds like a team Segway I gotta say it
was I didn't know you were going to do
that the bone regeneration Julian you
took me in a quiet Segway right all
right back to our decision here so if
you use the word tchotchkes if you don't
sit on Santa's lap at the mall right now
or if you clap on a plane with the San
is laughing that's getting a little
religious let's get that word out of
here
fan okay here's here's my logic okay if
you use the word tchotchkes and if you
coop or the plane lands my thing is
that's the same person one guy does both
right if you do one you do both those
things
ah the Pens of tchotchkes which is like
which is the lesser of two evils here if
you have to choose somebody to ban I
feel I personally feel victimized when
someone says tchotchkes three but at the
same time I'm ready to like get off the
plane and I don't want anyone clapping
why are you so excited early you think
someone's twisting your arm and you have
to pick put an even simulation to ruin
Jackie alright welcome to America where
if you say the word choppers earth earth
earth earth earth yeah so I gotta clean
gets louder louder alright hold on let
me see oh my god alright what do you got
if your initials are fu Frank under wake
under was
all right if you pull your pants all the
way down and shirt all the way up at a
standing urine good guys like butters in
South Park
I should add if you're over 15 yeah okay
if you have you're all doing on the year
where that fund if you have non-human
colored hair oh [ __ ]
I'm talked to like this one is human
Ruben coming but I'm had a DDM we can't
do this you have to ban so many people
that's just wrong I just think it's it's
a violate people around you if you pull
your pants all the way down under stand
up urinal well I mean we can't take out
all the people whose initials are askew
you actually that'd probably be easier
to logistically do but that's why we
should pick this one cuz it's harder to
[ __ ] are I pull off we are here to
make our bosses job difficult because
he's making [ __ ] los America where
it's all your fans all the way down and
you should all the way up any girl New
York is the loudest podcast ever of any
podcast here we go yeah here we go here
we go here we go
[Music]
if you pout if our thang if passed the
age of 11 you've ever pinched to those
human being on st. Patrick's and you man
if you've ever owned a fat head kit for
those who don't know what a fat head it
is a life-size poster
often of professional athletes and
celebrities that you can glue onto your
wall as a child or a weird adult
actually not weird I'm not going all in
if you want to Fathead get a Fathead
I have like I'm not cool I have a guy he
resided in the kitchen guy Yeti this is
the laughing it if you have one three
children the whole family is band
yes though who wrote that it looks like
your handwriting
[Music]
if you've ever owned a fat head I mean
here's the thing about that how in the
[ __ ] are you going to figure out who
ever owned the pad
it's the same as if that's the age of 11
you've ever pinched someone on st.
Patrick's Day right what's that hey this
is easier though if you've ever pinched
someone it's easier to not track like
they could track how to eat and harder
to track yeah yeah like it's big they
could track out if you bought anything
no no II couldn't because fat heads were
they were just so a phase so come on
know if you saw my pads in cash so
there's no tracing if you pinch someone
see Patrick say it requires a rat like
someone is to rat you out that brings
out the rats well I like to fun you
think that's a good thing yes what's
wrong with you we got the rats know is
so awesome ridiculous we're just trying
to figure out which one's the least like
that is release tab yeah that's what I
said no I like that breeze all right in
America under the age of 11 you never
really know st. Patrick's Day is bad
enough
Santa Monica in America yeah yeah oh oh
[ __ ] we got two more three more three
more three more two bits today are you
perfect if you'll [ __ ] ain't bug
grabbin you did if your nail polish
color bores me a little bit of your band
and if you don't think Ron and Sam are
better love story than the notebook then
your band your tears don't mean dick to
me we can't have this if you'll put the
ain't forgot we can't have this get that
out again another another terrible one
don't like that one see the nail polish
woman I think I just this is it's me and
stuck like when someone's nail polish
doesn't bother me but it bores me just a
little bit that is like a fence
like that well I mean look what was
imagine and I threw your thought process
that you picked that color I know that
they have more colors there I'm not sure
that Ron and Sam are a better love story
than the notebook so what's the notebook
Wow Dooley I forgot to you one time when
I was curious
you tear something [ __ ] to me your tears
don't mean dick to me I hope you know
that
which one which one's the law in the
United States Ron and Sam or if your
nail polish boards me very good a digit
yeah okay apparently if you don't think
that Ron and Sam are a better love story
than the notebook you can get out you
ban Oh beautiful beautiful we're
building a great fictitious country
right okay country litigate country very
country all right if you have glasses or
contacts called e none of this country
all right if you've ever washed your
hair with body wash you being blonde mm
all right here and this is between those
two and if you don't call Tim Gunn daddy
I really think everyone's called him go
Daddy
Susan his dad all right I'm down with it
thank yo call Tim go Daddy you are
banned from face of America you gotta
get banned if you have a refer to him as
pin got him done not daddy you be if you
say the sentence ever in your life with
Tim Gunn you're banned
because it's just an animal to to an
amendment to this life all right so the
final law we're debating between two
things there you go now you go you go
there you go if you have used the phrase
it's biodegradable as an excuse for
littering you're banned if you use your
Bluetooth headset loudly in public to
make phone calls these are both rough
these are like the same person
hmm which one well I mean I personally
think when people
click letter and then we thought about
agreeable like feel like it's a shitty
thing to do but this is like a conscious
shitty choice that everybody make every
day being but the point of the game is
that we have to just figure out which is
the less bad which is less which would
you be able to enforce in a law which
was pretty someone's presenting you
these to you not as likely we should I
going down I'm aware with a computer and
then a sensor and every Bluetooth just
immediately extradite those people okay
fado alright alright
welcome tiny country where you read you
read something or some alright it's bath
salts are on your maybe list let's say
let's just say your band at the way end
so if you as that's offering a list if
past the age of eleven you've ever
pinched another human being on st.
Patrick's Day if your Wi-Fi password is
a pun if you don't think Ron and Sam are
a better love story than the notebook if
you click bait on the Reg if you have a
problem with mammals if your brother is
a pussy-ass [ __ ] if you don't call him
go Daddy
if you use the word tchotchkes if you
use Bluetooth headset loudly in public
to make her goals you are also if you at
that honorable mention we're going to
revisit this law in a year potentially
enforce it don't be a 80s yell our
country so toe you said the word
tchotchkes by saying you can't use
chachi's carb and I also am banned from
half those things I'm saying I've use
party well I wonder [ __ ] ass [ __ ] I'm
out of here I've been [ __ ] up yes
you're a booted headset so I keep the
little ones you look at those you again
that's kind of tight yeah it's like the
[ __ ] dumbest thing in the world yes
well anyway I hope you guys enjoyed this
process I I know we did I like I'm glad
we were able to have them fun this week
I think it was necessary for
you love games and fun you can policy so
it's fun to play a game with you from
any game looking right out silly things
and laughs oh you ain't need that said
you eighty desk then you a knee in my
country mmm utopia well you guys
actually gonna get it Levi yeah yeah you
remember show heat okay a fear-eater
and then I got you know what you think
in traveling English is there is a show
called utopia terrible yeah we love
watching it was so bad but after like an
episode I am missing this is utopia she
singing baby we can bring to learn she's
continuing your themes like thank you
amy dad you ain't yes you ain't a dig
over here how do you guys play siding
fan